well guys welcome to another anime
review had the opportunity to this movie
in theaters tonight with my wife we had
a great time thanks for joining manager
view you look amazing you spend an hour
in front of the mirror true dedication
looks great no you look you look great
he look just like you sabi or Serena or
whatever dub you appreciate watching
she's fighting evil by moonlight she's
winning love by daylight that's right
she's the one she is Sailor Moon in this
case Sailor Moon are the movie biz media
has beautifully remastered and shown in
theaters which we got to see tonight
there's still one more showing of this
movie on the 25th that's going to be
Japanese with English subtitles but
since we grew up with the dub I think
it's one of those animes that you kind
of have to watch it with a doubly truss
please dress yeah I mean it's the same
thing with Dragon Ball Z I just I can't
watch the Japanese dub on that it's like
Sailor Moon Khan's the same way and you
have to share with anyone I can't watch
pretty much anything that we like when
we were young and we first saw for the
first time it's like you want the voices
you or at least close to the voices you
remember because this is a new dub and
that's one of the things that we
definitely talk about is the fact that
this is the first time this movies being
shown in America completely uncut
because this original VHS that I grew up
with was heavily censored and Mary
something I think Sailor Moon in general
was pretty Americanized back in the day
yes like most animated came to our
country got very heavily censored in
terms of it removed anything that was
hentai or it was Yahweh our Yuri yeah
all that's gone all is gone now it's
like it's back it's an original form
some things actually make more sense now
because it's back in because there was
something jars just like huh it's true I
remember watching it for the first time
on that VHS thinking I really enjoyed
that movie it was fun guilty pleasure it
just silly good time and that's how kind
of how I viewed Sailor Moon it's just a
big fun guilty pleasure it's so cheesy
it's so silly and over-the-top but I've
always loved it and I have no problem
saying that because I'm a man
and men are loud like Sailor Moon in my
opinion oh just my opinion you're
talking about the fiance as part of that
oh man I'd like that too but I also have
a deep connection with Sailor Moon
on an emotional level and don't judge me
he had a crush on her or one of the
other sailors on cheese I'm not sure
which but it's true this does make more
sense watching this more streamlined
version of the story which just in case
you don't know this some essentially
about young Tuxedo Mask or Mamoru as
he's known in Japanese when he was a
little boy his parents were killed and
he befriended a young boy named Fiore
who banished and promised one day he'd
come back and bring him flowers or
something because I was sort of their
little connection they had with each
other yeah he comes back as an adult he
has a grudge of some kind he might be
under a spell it's you know I don't want
to spoil it for you but if you've never
seen this movie I personally think it's
ton of fun so fun it's just funny the
entire thing he just makes people laugh
intense times it's fun who cares right
here was roaring the flat write an
entire time yes it is silly yes it's
over-the-top yes it has hilariously
stupid lines yes there's all these
repeat sequences of them getting their
powers and putting on their suits and
announcing everything they're about to
do kind of like the Power Rangers
announce everything they do before they
do it everything they could spend like
two minutes announcing their powers in
the bag I could just kill them if they
really wanted to when they're announcing
it but it knows it it knows that it's
silly it relishes it it's just like hey
this is what we are enjoy it
why do you appreciate because it's just
it's just good fun it's so silly I mean
I know it's like 20 almost 30 years old
at this point they came out in 93 right
it's almost 30 years old of this one
yeah it's pretty crazy those close to my
birthday want to flash that flash that
right
I'm not almost turning 35 no you are not
a woman ah the thing that for me makes
this movie work is and really the show
or the characters they're more fleshed
out than you might expect even in a
short movie like this because it's about
their bond you know it's about the
friendship that they all have and the
fact that they all are sort of wounded
people that were
loners didn't have too many friends so
you can connect with them and because of
you soggy they all kind of come together
as a team and so it's cheesy yeah but as
a good message for kids you know if you
watch the movie when you're younger or
the show it's it's like look you might
be a loner you might have problems you
might not have a lot of friends that's
okay you can still be a badass
it's supposed to be whimsical it's must
be funny but also specific a little
lessons about things like greed jealousy
anger most the time they're fighting
things that are feeding off some strong
negative emotions I ran home from school
two watches when I was on tsunami it was
like I was one of the first shows from
like 4:00 p.m. I think on tsunami and I
usually missed the first few minutes
because my bus I was one of the last
stops so my bus got there pretty late
probably around like 355 p.m. and I
would just - of like Toonami starting
five minutes was get this going yeah I
remember being a little kid and they
came on in the morning so I would
literally skip getting on the bus and
how my grandmother take me to school
so I watch Sailor Moon in the morning
and that's dedication because I mean I
have an hour and 20 minute bus ride
that's long as hell that's a really long
bus ride sighs oh that
for Sailor Moon Sailor Moon get to sleep
a little bit longer get breakfast and
then go to school
I just glad cause I was the first pickup
on in the morning let's talk about some
of the things they have most definitely
put back into this movie that was
originally not in that version now
there's less of a friendship vibe going
on with Fiore and Tuxedo Mask and it's
certainly I think there's more of a
romantic love especially in Fiore from
his standpoint that yeah more of a
romantic affection that he has he is
very controlling there's even a park
he's like I'm the only one is allowed to
give you flowers
yes very controlling yeah yeah the
officer back in the lines that's where
the girls are sitting at Ray's house and
I'm talking about how hola totally okay
no people are gay and they know people
who are it's probably cool world a was
outside to love whatever because he just
happens to be in a relationship with
Saudi at the moment it doesn't want to
be in relationship with Fiore like in
the 90s whoever had the rights to this
they were like oh
don't know that old I'm too sexual Olga
are some so they made it like they took
out all that subtext it did the same
thing with the show they had the the
cousins right I was at Neptune and
Uranus yeah they were not cousins who
were definitely not cousins they were
most definitely lovers later in the
series and they did that was a lot of
serious we got Cardcaptor Sakura
Sakura's older brother and his best
friend in the American version were
actually in the Japanese version and
very much in love with each other and
even have Sakura's boyfriend at one
point be thinking maybe he has a crush
on
Sakura's older brother's boyfriend so
there's a long history of this one of
the biggest accusers was four kids that
was a company that did a lot of anime I
think that Pokemon and you do and
Digimon and they even did I think they
did some edits of DBZ back in the day
and they are atrocious at it it's like
hey let's just make everything Looney
Toons right but it's really nice to see
this movie in theaters on cuts
beautifully remastered by the way this
will be looking great they did a really
good job with the transfer I think the
humor is there I think they retained the
humor of these characters the tragic
backstory of some of the characters
actually is there it's not kitty if I'd
it's not like you know all your parents
they just were dreadfully injured in a
car crash your parents died
sorry they're dead like it's it's their
and I really appreciate that as you said
this is a fanservice fun guilty pleasure
silly movie and the way I view Sailor
Moon is you already know if you like it
if you like Sailor Moon already you're
going to like this movie if you've never
heard of Sailor Moon before just don't
eat you only have to watch it sailor is
one of the scene for us you didn't like
it or you're not gonna like it
that's it is either going to be you fall
in love with these characters it does
take a while to like get really into it
it's totally guilty pleasure thing but I
love it yeah and you start to grow with
these characters they mature through the
series so the movie just kind of plays
right into them maturing so eventually
the end of it yeah I read the mom does
too so I have a lot more gaps in regards
to some of the stuff that goes on but
the anime doesn't really good job of
making it obvious but manga was trying
to present yeah I think when when you
are
a fan of the anime and you've read the
manga and you have all that backstory
it's easy to take that and just sort of
attribute it to this movie and you feel
like you you already know and you go
along with it
I said the same thing in my reviews of
the the two most recent Dragon Ball Z
movie style of gods and resurrection F
if you just walk into those kind of like
what the hell is going on but if you
already appreciate these character then
you're going to enjoy more and I think I
had a great time with this movie I think
we both the whole audience oh my god
everybody loved that people were like
cosplaying and everything so there's
little kids there Debra dress that they
has a little sailor Senshi outfits on
it's adorable
it's like older parents that were our
age brought their kids who were middle
school elementary school-aged children
which is kind of hard to think about but
boy are that when I started watching
this right that's where I started
watching on the show and now there's
people our age with kids that age right
weird
I always connected more with Jupiter and
Mercury because more like them
and as the Advocate Sailor Senshi the
books on their reading yeah
I'm cooking yeah look cooking books
making me very protective of my friends
and very much willing to beat the
out of guy being a bit of a loner had a
lot of pressure to do good in school I
fell for them more yeah I've always
loved the characters in the show and in
the movie in particular I think it's the
best Sailor Moon movie I think it's
really well directed in regards to what
they're trying to do it's fast paced as
good action as good characters good
humor I like the fact that Fiore is like
this really damaged goods character and
it has some actual mature themes in
there as well so in the long run like I
said if you've never seen Sailor Moon
this movie isn't going to appeal to you
if you've never seen it and don't care
about anime in general I certainly would
not recommend this but if you already
like Sailor Moon like we do then you're
probably going to enjoy this movies just
like we did I'm going to give Sailor
Moon are the movie and a mine and I'm
going to give feeling moon our puppy
plus cool very similar yeah definitely
again thank you very much for joining me
on this video you look lovely thanks
very much for seeing the film it was a
lot of fun I'm always happy to go see
films with you like stuff you like when
you get to see anime in theaters so that
you can get to see more anime indeed
it's a rare opportunity
it really is Liam thinks I can get these
off my head
okay guys thank you so much as always
for watching I also look forward to more
animators here and look forward to more
anime reviews I'm trying to do more in
my channel guys thank you very much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck my knives
[Applause]
[Music]